- MM.
THAT WAS GREAT.
WE GOT IT.
TERRIFIC.
DO YOU WANT TO WRAP, OR DO
YOU WANT TO PUNCH ANYBODY OUT?
THAT'S PRETTY IRISH.
- DID YOU SEE WHAT JUST HAPPENED
WITH MY WIFE?
- YOUR EX-WIFE IS A NUT JOB.
- WHAT?
- LOOK, THE IRISH SUFFER.
IT'S IN THEIR BLOOD, OKAY?
IT'S TRADITION.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
- HMM?
- YOU'RE THE ONE WHO TOLD ME
ABOUT THE GUY
WHO WAITED AND WAITED
AND WAITED AND WAITED
UNTIL A LITTLE BIT OF FUNGUS
TURNED INTO PENICILLIN.
- MM.
- AND THIS IRISH SEQUENCE
IS VERY CLOSE
TO BECOMING PENICILLIN...
THANKS TO YOU.
- IS THAT ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY?
- WELL, THOSE WERE YOUR WORDS,
AND I THINK THEY SAY A LOT.
- YOU KNOW, GRANT,
WHEN I STARTED HERE,
I BELIEVED IN WHAT
WE WERE DOING,
BUT NOW I'M NOT SO SURE.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING
I DO KNOW.
YOU'RE THE BIGGEST JAG-OFF
I'VE EVER WORKED FOR,
AND I HOPE THIS PLACE BURNS
TO THE GROUND WITH YOU IN IT,
'CAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU DESERVE,
YOU NICKEL-AND-DIME
CHICKEN[bleep] MOTHER[bleep]!
[normal voice]
YOU CALL YOURSELF A PRODUCER?
YOU COULDN'T PRODUCE
A HAM SANDWICH!
NOW I AM WALKING OUT
THAT DOOR,
AND I AM NEVER COMING BACK,
NOT IF YOU BEG ME!
I QUIT!
[all cheering]
- YEAH!
- AND ONE MORE THING!
all: OH!
[cheering]
- CATCH HIM.
DON'T LET HIM GET AWAY!
FORREST!
DON'T LET HIM GET AWAY.
DO YOU HAVE HIM?
- SUZANNE!
SUZANNE!
- OKAY, WEIRDLY ENOUGH, FORREST
HAS ACTUALLY NOT BEEN SEEN
BY ANYONE HERE AT THE SHOW
SINCE THAT NIGHT,
SO IT SEEMS LIKE
HE REALLY DID QUIT FOR REAL,
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY UNPROFESSIONAL.